This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Earlier this year, the city of New York closed off several blocks around the Manhattan criminal courthouse. Instead of early morning commuters, the sidewalks around the building were flooded with reporters, photographers, and camera people. They were there to capture the arrangement of former President Donald Trump. Members of the media were so desperate to get a good shot that they camped out overnight outside the courthouse, and it's because people all over the world
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今年早些时候，纽约市封闭了曼哈顿刑事法院周围的几个街区。大楼周围的人行道上挤满了记者、摄影师和摄像师，而不是清晨通勤的人。他们去那是为了拍摄前总统唐纳德·特朗普的提审。媒体成员迫切地想要拍到好镜头，以至于他们在法院外通宵露营，这是因为世界各地的人们
demanded an immediate visual record of this historic moment. Viewers were hoping to watch Trump's perp walk into the courtroom or see his mugshot, or see a video of him being read his felony charges, and said the image that was everywhere, from the guardian to the Washington Post, even the cover of the New Yorker. That image was a hand-drawn courtroom sketch. I cannot stress to you how much I really, really, really did not want to begin this episode talking about Donald Trump. But this was a really great sketch.
都要求为这个历史性时刻留下即时的视觉记录。观众们希望能看到特朗普被押送进法庭的过程、他的面部照片，或者他被宣读重罪指控的视频，并表示这幅图片无处不在，从《卫报》到《华盛顿邮报》，甚至还登上了《纽约客》的封面。那张图片是一幅手绘法庭速写。我怎么强调都不为过，我是真的、真的、真的很不想从谈论唐纳德·特朗普开始这期节目。但这确实是一幅非常棒的速写。
Producer Vivienne Leigh. The sketch was done by a New York-based artist named Jane Rosenberg. She portrayed Trump at a three-quarter profile, his arms crossed in a defiant manner. Somehow Rosenberg managed to portrayed Trump at a three-quarter profile, his arms crossed in a defiant manner. Somehow Rosenberg managed to perfectly encapsulate his hair with just a few messy strokes of an oil pastel. His face was frozen in a deep cutting scale, emanating what I can only describe as sour-puss energy. I've always found court-room art fascinating. When I look at a sketch, it doesn't feel like I'm looking at a moment frozen in time.
制作人薇薇安·莱。这幅速写由一位常驻纽约的艺术家简·罗森伯格创作。她将特朗普描绘成四分之三侧面，双手以挑衅的姿态交叉。不知何故，罗森伯格设法将特朗普描绘成四分之三侧面，双手以挑衅的姿态交叉。不知何故，罗森伯格设法只用油粉彩的几笔凌乱笔触，就完美地概括了他的发型。他的脸上凝固着一种深沉而刻薄的表情，散发着我只能将其形容为“臭脸”的能量。我一直觉得法庭艺术很迷人。当我看着一幅速写时，感觉不像是看着一个定格在时间里的时刻，
It feels like I'm looking at a memory of a moment, like I'm seeing it through the artist's eyes and watching the gears turning in their brain. I was in love with it from the very beginning. It's always different. It's emotional. I carry around stories with me, you know, in my head for months and months. This is Mona Schaefer Edwards, a quarter-marthist based in Los Angeles. It's very satisfying to see justice being done and to have the historical presence and to watch history unfold.
倒更像是看着某个时刻的记忆，就像是通过艺术家的眼睛在看，并看着他们大脑中的齿轮在转动。我从一开始就爱上了它。它总是与众不同的。它是充满情感的。你知道的，我在脑海里带着这些故事好几个月又好几个月。这是莫娜·谢弗·爱德华兹，一位常驻洛杉矶的法庭艺术家。看到正义得到伸张，拥有历史的现场感，并看着历史展开，这是非常令人满足的。
So I have covered some of the most important trials in American history in the last 35, 40 years. She's drawn a ton of big cases. Michael Jackson, the Night Stalker, Harvey Weinstein. I can imagine LA is you get a lot of work. I'm right with disaster. Yes, is get a lot of work. I live with disaster, yes, I get a lot of work. But I think the most fascinating thing to me about courtroom illustration is that it still exists.
所以我报道过过去35、40年里美国历史上一些最重要的审判。她画过大量的大案。迈克尔·杰克逊、夜行者、哈维·韦恩斯坦。我可以想象洛杉矶你会得到很多工作。我正与灾难为伴。是的，会得到很多工作。我与灾难生活在一起，是的，我得到了很多工作。但我认为法庭插画最吸引我的地方在于，它竟然还存在着。
Because you can't really talk about courtroom illustration without addressing the elephant not in the room. Photography. What can a really good, or a illustrator do that a photographer can't do, like specifically? Like what was your edge? I can't compete with photography. You know, I'm not going to justify what I do. I can't compete with the camera. Next to a camera, pastel on paper feels like an archaic way of documenting some of the most important legal events
因为你无法在不谈论“房间里那头不在的大象”的情况下真正谈论法庭插画。摄影。一个真正优秀的插画师能做什么，是摄影师做不到的，比如具体来说？就像你的优势是什么？我无法与摄影竞争。你知道的，我不会为我做的事辩解。我无法与相机竞争。在相机旁边，纸上的粉彩画感觉就像是一种记录我们时代一些最重要的法律事件的古老方式，
of our time. Cameras are faster, easier, and more accurate than a human illustrator. But for some reason, courtroom artists are still constantly used in high-profile cases. The answer to how courtroom artists have managed to survive the camera for so long is wrapped up in a decades-long tug of war between transparency and integrity in the courts.
相机比人类插画家更快、更轻松、也更准确。但出于某种原因，法庭艺术家仍然经常被用于备受瞩目的案件中。法庭艺术家如何在相机面前存活这么长时间，这个问题的答案包裹在法庭透明度与诚信之间长达数十年的拉锯战中。
It's a nearly-century long battle that centers around the question of whether it's even possible to observe the justice system without changing the course of justice. It's attention that came to a head for the first time in 1932. Tum-tum. We've always been big on crime in America, Vivian. This is Tom Astority, author of a book called Little Lindy's Kidnapped, which focuses entirely on the media coverage surrounding the kidnapping and grizzly murder of the infant son of Charles
这是一场近一个世纪的斗争，核心问题是：在不改变正义进程的情况下，是否有可能去观察司法系统。这种紧张关系在1932年第一次达到了顶峰。咚咚。维维安，我们在美国一向对犯罪很感兴趣。这是汤姆·阿斯特里蒂，一本书的作者，书名叫《小林德伯格被绑架》，这本书完全聚焦于围绕查尔斯·林德伯格婴儿儿子的绑架和残忍谋杀案的媒体报道。
Lindbergh. Lindbergh's reputation has since tarnished because of his isolationist views and his political sympathies. Not see. But at the time, Lindbergh was one of the most well-known and most well-respected men in the country, when tragedy struck. On the night of March 1st, 1932, and there are a state in Hopewell, New Jersey, someone comes in to the second floor nursery,
林德伯格的声誉此后因为他的孤立主义观点和政治同情心而受损。纳粹。但在当时，当悲剧降临时，林德伯格是该国最知名、最受尊敬的男子之一。1932年3月1日的夜晚，在新泽西州霍普韦尔的庄园里，有人进入了二楼的育儿室，
climbs up on the ladder, goes into the baby's nursery, and takes him away that night. Not a single bed is overlooked. Not a single suspicion unverified in the search for the most famous baby in the world. Innocent, 20-month-old son of the lone eagle. And the kidnapper leaves a note, demanding $50,000 in ransom. Sadly, the limberg son was never recovered alive.
爬上梯子，进入婴儿的育儿室，并在那天晚上把他带走了。在寻找全世界最著名的婴儿的过程中，没有放过一张床，也没有未经证实的怀疑。孤独之鹰无辜的20个月大的儿子。绑架者留下一张纸条，索要5万美元赎金。可悲的是，林德伯格的儿子再也没有被活著找回。
The child's body was discovered less than five miles from the limberg home, and police later charged a German-born immigrant named Bruno Richard Helpman with the murder. And then, on January 2nd, 1935, the crime of the century gives way to the trial of the century. Everyone wanted to taste it this story, and the press was more than happy to provide that access. About 700 reporters, photographers, and camera operators descended upon New Jersey were helped men with standing trial.
孩子的尸体在离林德伯格家不到五英里远的地方被发现，警方随后指控一名出生于德国的移民布鲁诺·理查德·豪普曼谋杀。然后，在1935年1月2日，“世纪犯罪”让位给了“世纪审判”。每个人都想尝尝这个故事的味道，而媒体也非常乐意提供这种接触。大约700名记者、摄影师和摄像操作员蜂拥至新泽西州，豪普曼将在那里接受审判。
Oh, there's a media scrum. Yeah. Look at this scene. A courtroom self-packed that is not an inch of space available, while excited, chatter, and bars filled the air. At this time, motion picture cameras, which had only recently entered the courtroom, were these clunky masses of metal that took up a lot of space and made a worrying noise. And even still photographers weren't subtle. You know, still photographer.
哦，这里有一场媒体争夺战。是的。看看这个场景。法庭内挤得水泄不通，没有一英寸的空闲空间，而兴奋的闲聊声和喧闹声充满了空气。在这个时候，刚刚进入法庭的电影摄影机还是那种占用大量空间并发出令人烦躁的噪音的大块头金属。即便如此，静态摄影师也不是低调的。你知道，静态摄影师。
I had those old-fashioned light bulbs in their camera that to give you the flash and the reporters that take the bulb out of the light and then toss it on the floor where to make a popping sound. So that could be quite intrusive. The judge was concerned about all the distraction photographers and camera reels would have. So he strictly forbade any photography or motion picture captured during the course of the
他们的相机里有那种老式的灯泡来提供闪光，记者们会把灯泡从灯上取下来，然后扔在地板上以发出一声爆裂声。所以这可能相当具有侵扰性。法官对摄影师和摄像机带来的所有干扰感到担忧，因此他严格禁止在审判过程中进行任何摄影或电影拍摄。
trial. Camera operators were only to capture the moments before court was in session and after. The newsreels promise him, on their honor, that the newsreel camera they have in the balcony of the courtroom will only be turned on when people aren't on the stand doing actual testimony. Believe it or not, they didn't do that. During the dramatic cross-examination between Bruno Gritjud helpman, the accused kidnapped murderer, and David T. Wollentz, the prosecutor, when they're having this really vociferous
摄像操作员只能拍摄庭审开始前和结束后的时刻。新闻短片制作人向法官以名誉担保，他们在法庭阳台上设置的新闻短片摄像机，只有在人们不在证人席上进行实际作证时才会开启。信不信由你，他们并没有那样做。在被告绑架杀人犯布鲁诺·理查德·豪普曼与检察官大卫·T·沃伦茨之间激烈的交叉询问期间，当他们进行这种非常激烈的对抗时。
confrontation. During that moment, I think if you or I were a newsreel guy, we might have done the same thing, which is we betray the judge, turn on our cameras and record the actual confrontation on film. During this rapid cross-examination, Halftman admits to having lied to police on the stand. Think you lied to Lord, did you tell the truth?
在那一刻，我想如果你或我是一个新闻短片制作者，我们可能会做同样的事情，那就是背叛法官，打开摄像机，将实际的对抗记录在胶片上。在这场快速的交叉询问中，豪普曼在证人席上承认曾向警方撒谎。你觉得你对主撒谎了吗，你说了实话吗？
I said nothing to Lord. Good luck! I did, yes. Yeah. stand. Shortly after Helmines questioning the news reel footage of his interrogation spread quickly, playing two packed movie houses around New York City. Eager Patrons lined up around the block to watch the bombastic courtroom scene. The public saw everybody in America's riled up and when the jury finally goes in to deliberate the case, there are packs of people around the courthouse and the mob starts to get a little unruly and disruptive
我没有对主说什么。祝你好运！我说了，是的。是的。证人席。在豪普曼受审后不久，他接受审讯的新闻短片镜头迅速传播开来，在纽约市各个挤满人的电影院上映。急切的顾客在街区周围排起长队观看这个夸张的法庭场景。公众看到美国的所有人都被激怒了，当陪审团最终进入进行案件审议时，法院周围聚集了一群群人，随着陪审团审议时间比大多数人认为的要长几个小时，人群开始变得有些难以控制和具有破坏性，
as the jury deliberation goes on for a few hours longer than most people thought it should have gone on and they start screaming, kill the German, kill Haltenmann. A rock goes through the window with a courthouse. But the jury returns its verdict. Bruno Haltenmann was found guilty and was sentenced to death by electric chair. Although it's unclear how much, or even if the leaked footage had any impact on the verdict, the world was appalled by the carnival-like atmosphere that the press had created during the trial.
他们开始尖叫，杀死德国人，杀死豪普曼。一块石头穿过了法院的窗户。但陪审团交出了裁决。布鲁诺·豪普曼被判有罪，并被判处电椅死刑。尽管目前尚不清楚泄露的镜头在多大程度上（甚至是否）对裁决产生了任何影响，但世界对媒体在审判期间制造的嘉年华般的氛围感到震惊。
Many in the judicial system believed that the presence of photographers, newsreels, and other journalists made a complete mockery of the court. I think the prime argument you might make is a baby has been murdered and we want to see justice done. And of course, we want to give the accused proper due process and we don't want to allow anything to sort of interject itself into what at its best is really a solemn process, a democratic process, one in which we, I think, genuinely want to see justice done. They were also arguments that cameras didn't just tarnish the solemnity of the courtroom process, they could possibly interfere with our constitutional right to a fair trial. After all, how could a trial
司法系统的许多人认为，摄影师、新闻短片和其他记者的存在完全是对法庭的嘲弄。我认为你可能会提出的主要论点是，一个婴儿被谋杀了，我们希望看到正义得到伸张。当然，我们希望给予被告适当的正义程序，我们不希望允许任何东西插足于这个在其最佳状态下真正庄严的过程、民主的过程——一个我们认为真正希望看到正义得到伸张的过程。也有人认为，相机不仅玷污了法庭审判过程的庄严性，还可能干涉我们获得公正审判的宪法权利。毕竟，将所有这些外部热情和影响带入法庭，审判怎么可能是公正的呢？
be fair with all of this outside passion and influence brought into the courtroom? So in direct response to the Helpman trial, the American Bar Association adopted something called Canon 35. Canon 35 condemned the use of photography, motion picture, and radio recording within the confines of the courtroom. It wasn't a law per se, but a code of ethics
因此，作为对豪普曼审判的直接回应，美国律师协会通过了所谓的“第35号准则”（Canon 35）。第35号准则谴责在法庭范围内使用摄影、电影和无线电录音。它本身不是一项法律，而是一套道德准则，警告在审判过程中不要使用记录技术。许多州都采纳了这一政策。1946年，美国政府走得更远，明确禁止所有摄像机进入联邦法院。
that cautioned against recording technology in the trial process. In many states adopted that policy. In 1946, the US government went even further and expressly banned all cameras from federal courts. And so starving sketch artists are the people that really, I think benefit from this from Canon 35. The rise of the courtroom artist was also driven
因此，穷困潦倒的速写艺术家才是真正从第35号准则中受益的人。法庭艺术家的崛起在某种程度上也是由电视推动的。到了20世纪60年代，电视已经成为大多数美国家庭的标配。夜间电视新闻节目不断演变，以报道当天的重大事件，对了解备受瞩目的法庭案件内部情况的需求也达到了空前的水平。但由于不允许摄像机进入，法庭成了一个视觉上的黑匣子。因此，电视网决定，允许艺术家进入法庭是一个可以接受的漏洞，既能遵循第35号准则的精神，又能让公众一窥法庭内部。
in part by television. By the 1960s, television had become a staple in most American households. Nightly TV news programs were evolving to cover the big events of the day, and there's more demand than ever to see inside high-profile court cases. But with no cameras allowed in, the courtroom was a visual black box. So television networks decided that allowing artists into the courtroom was an acceptable loophole that would follow the spirit of Canon 35 while still giving the public a peak inside the court.
为电视绘制审判速写的第一批人之一是一个名叫霍华德·布罗迪的人。1964年，布罗迪被CBS晚间新闻雇用，为刺杀李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的杰克·鲁比的审判创作视觉效果。其他电视网也纷纷效仿，开始与法庭艺术家合作。鲁迪的工作将法庭插画变成了一份真正的工作，并为许多其他有抱负的艺术家开辟了这个行业。他完成了一场重大、重大的谋杀审判，我看到了那些画作，简直太着迷了，我知道不知何故
One of the first people to sketch a trial for television was a man named Howard Brody. Brody was hired by the CBS Evening News in 1964 to create the visuals for the trial of Jack Ruby, the man convicted of killing Lee Harvey Allswald. Other networks followed suit and began teaming up with artists in the courtroom. Rudy's work turned courtroom illustration into a real job and broke open the profession for a number of other aspiring artists. He had completed a major, major murder trial and I saw those drawings and was just so mesmerized, I knew somehow that
我也能做到同样的事情。这是帕特·洛佩斯，她是一位常驻新墨西哥州的艺术家。在帕特在CBS上看到霍华德·布罗迪的那些画作后，她给当地新闻台的一位制作人打了电话，并争取到了一次会面。所以我跑去电视台，他让我当场画午间新闻主播在播报新闻时的样子，然后他说，你是从街上走进来应聘的吗？我说是的，先生。因为他们需要为接下来的周一找一个法庭艺术家。
I could do the same thing. This is Pat Lopez, she's an artist based in New Mexico. After Pat saw those Howard Brody drawings on CBS, she called up a producer at her local news station and scored a meeting. So I ran to the station, he had me draw the noon anchor as he was giving the news right in front of him and then he said said and you walked in off the street I said yes sir Because they needed a courtroom artist for the following Monday
所以那是我的第一个挑战，我想我通过了测试，因为我从那以后就一直在做这个。帕特自20世纪70年代以来一直在做法庭插画，并为安然事件、马修·谢泼德谋杀案和俄克拉荷马城爆炸案等审判创作了法庭速写。她说，法庭艺术家之所以兴起，部分原因在于他们没有像摄影师那样背负沉重的包袱。每个人都知道法庭里有摄像机，
So that was my first ever challenge and I guess I passed the test because I've been doing it ever since Path's been doing courtroom illustration since the 1970s, and has created the courtroom sketches for trials like Enron, the Matthew Shepherd murder trial, and the Oklahoma City bomber. She says that part of the reason that courtroom artist took off is that they didn't carry the same baggage as photographers. Everyone knows when the cameras in the courtroom,
但当你像我这样坐在第一排安静地速写时，你知道的，没有人真的知道我在做什么，他们真的不知道我在做什么。他们看不到我在做什么。与举着相机的摄影师不同，速写艺术家能够安静地融入房间。没有人会担心审判参与者会分心，或者证人会感到太害怕而不敢作证，或者陪审员会担心他们的隐私会受到威胁。
but you've got someone like me sitting on the front row quietly sketching, you know, no one really knows what I'm doing, they can really knows what I'm doing. They can't see what I'm doing. Unlike a photographer holding up a camera, a sketch artist has the ability to quietly blend into the room. No one was worried that the trial participants would become distracted, or that witnesses would feel too intimidated to testify, or that jurors would be fearful that their privacy
这正是法官们想要的，是对法庭内人们的一种保护。为了保护正义，我认为他们将法庭艺术视为做到这一点的最安全方式。像帕特这样的艺术家通常由电视网直接雇用，以便为广播报道备受瞩目的案件。这是一份压力极大的工作。你需要工作准确，同样重要的是，你需要工作迅速。有成千上万出色的插画师，
would be at stake. This is what the judges wanted was some kind of protection for the people in court. To protect justice, I think, that they looked at court-room art as the safest way to do this. Artists like Pat are usually hired directly by a television network in order to cover high-profile cases for broadcast. It's an incredibly high-pressure job. You need to work accurately and just as important, you need to work quickly. There are tons of fabulous illustrators,
但只有极少数人能够看着一个场景，并在五分钟、十分钟、二十分钟内把它画下来，并以那么快的速度讲完故事。这是艺术家莫娜·谢弗·爱德华兹。我知道我需要做什么。我们等待那个速度。这是艺术家莫娜·谢弗·爱德华兹。我知道我需要做什么。我们等待那个时刻。我相信每个插画师都会做同样的事情。你等待“啊哈”时刻。我的意思是，那是，你知道的，某人崩溃、尖叫、做手势或跳过桌子去试图勒死某人。我的意思是，那简直就像是黄金。我最喜欢的法庭艺术作品之一出自另一位名叫比尔·罗伯斯的插画家。
but there are very, very few people who can look at a scene and get it down in five minutes, ten minutes, 20 minutes, and tell the story that fast. This is artist Mona Schaefer Edwards again. I know what I need to do. We wait for that fast. This is artist Mona Schaefer Edwards again. I know what I need to do. We wait for that moment. I'm sure every illustrator will do the same thing. You wait for the aha moment. I mean, that's, you know, somebody collapsing or screaming or gesturing or jumping over a table to try and strangles someone. I mean, that's, that's like gold." One of my favorite pieces of courtroom art is from another illustrator named Bill Robles.
他记录了查尔斯·曼森的审判，在某个时刻，曼森变得如此情绪激动，以至于他冲过法庭去袭击法官。曼森双臂伸展，而一名法警从腰间扑倒了他。罗伯斯只有一分一秒的时间用钢笔和马克笔画下这个狂乱的场景。从风格上讲，它看起来几乎就像一本疯狂的罗尔德·达尔书中的插画。在联邦法院发生过这样一个时刻，白吉尔——一个坏家伙——他看到我在画他。
He documented the trial of Charles Manson, and at one point, Manson became so agitated that he lunged across the courtroom to attack the judge. Manson had his arms outstretched, while a bailiff tackled him around the waist. Robles had just a split second to scratch out the frantic scene using a pen and markers. Stylistically, it almost looks like an illustration from a deranged, rolled doll book. There was a moment in federal court, Y.D. Bulger, who was a bad guy, and he saw me sketching him.
现在，他在玻璃后面，所以离我很远。但他看到我在画他。现在我们落后了。他在玻璃后面。所以他离我很远。但他看到我在画他。他看着我，笑了笑，指着我并摇了摇手指。就像“不，别那样做”。尽管他离我，我不知道，我要说是15英尺远，10英尺远，而且在玻璃后面，但他真的吓到我了。帕特·洛佩斯告诉我，在她的职业生涯中，她也见过很多艰难的事情。
Now, he was behind glass, so he was far away from me. But he saw me sketching him. Now we were behind. He was behind glass. So he was far away from me. But he saw me sketching him. And he looked at me and he smiled and he pointed at me and wagged his finger. Like no, don't do that. And even though he was, I don't know, I'm gonna say 15 feet away, 10 feet away, and behind glass, he really scared me. Pat Lopez told me that she's also seen a lot of difficult things throughout the course of her career.
法庭内的能量有时真的非常非常黑暗。来到法庭的人们带着如此多的悲伤、仇恨的能量和复仇的能量，对于许多这些审判来说，里面有一个艺术家来创作法庭上发生的事情的场景，要容易得多。法庭出了名是一个人们经历生命中最糟糕日子的黑洞。帕特认为她自己和其他速写艺术家的工作正在做的一件事，就是传达审判的故事，同时避开摄像机可能会带入法庭的任何额外的紧张层。但并不是每个人都对法庭速写经过策划的平静感到满意。支持
The energy in the courtroom was really, really dark at times. The people coming into the court had so much grief and energy of hate and energy of revenge and for many of these trials that have an artist in there to create the scene in the court as to what happened. That's so much easier. The courtroom is notoriously a place where people experience the worst days of their lives. One thing that Pat sees her work and the work of other sketch artists doing is communicating the story of a trial while sidestepping any extra layer of tension that cameras might bring along with them into the courtroom. But not everyone is satisfied with the curated calm of a courtroom sketch. Proponents of
在法庭上使用摄像机的人认为，公众不应该依赖于被告知法律法庭上发生了什么，他们应该能够亲眼看到它的实际运作。如果你字面上在掌控人们的生死，我认为你必须准备好接受这种程度的公众审视。这是简·柯特利，明尼苏达大学媒体伦理与法律的资深教授。她长期以来一直倡导扩大摄像机进入法庭的权限。对我来说，根本的问题是，如果公众不知道发生了什么，他们怎么能信任法庭上正在发生的事情？
cameras in courtrooms think that the public shouldn't have to rely on being told what was happening in a court of law they should be able to see it in action for themselves. If you're presiding over literally life and death for people, I think you have to be prepared to be subject to that degree of public scrutiny. This is Jane Kertley, still hot professor of media ethics and law at the University of Minnesota. She's been a long time advocate for the expansion of camera access in courtrooms. To me, the fundamental question is, how can the public trust what's going on
如果那里发生的事情不是我们作为社会想要发生的事情，那么公众应该能够知道这一点，并应该能够采取步骤纠正这种情况。把他们挡在外面只会使情况变得更糟，并使系统更不具问责性。从一开始，第35号准则与其说是一项法律，不如说是一个措辞强烈的建议。到了20世纪60年代，在第35号准则发布三十年后，新的观念开始侵蚀在法庭摄像机前筑起的墙。
in the courtroom if they don't know what's happening? And if what's happening there is not what we as a society want to have happen, then the public should be able to know that and should be able to take steps to rectify that situation. Keeping them out only makes the situation worse and makes the system less accountable. From the beginning, Canon 35 was more of a strongly worded suggestion than a law. By the 1960s, three decades after Canon 35, new sensibilities started to erode the
那些推动摄像机进入法庭的人辩称，它们提供了对司法系统的增强监督。与此同时，电视和摄影记者则辩称，凭借他们更安静、更现代的摄像技术，他们的存在现在和低调的法庭艺术家一样不会引人注目。证人和律师不仅不会感到被吓到，甚至几乎不会注意到摄像机的存在。媒体倡导者还认为，转播审判为那些无法亲自到法庭但又想更多了解法律系统的人提供了一个极好的教育资源。因此，从20世纪70年代开始，不同的州法院开始忽略该准则，并开始试验对司法程序的广播报道。
wall erected against cameras in the courtroom. Those who were pushing for cameras argued that they offered increased oversight of the justice system. Meanwhile, television and photojournalists were making the case that with their quieter, modern camera technology, their presence was now just as unobtrusive as the discrete courtroom artist. Far from being intimidated, witnesses and lawyers would barely notice the cameras were there. Media advocates also believed that televising trials offered a great educational resource for people who couldn't physically be in a courtroom, but wanted to learn more about the legal system. So beginning in the 1970s, different state courts began ignoring the canon and experimenting
到了20世纪90年代，大多数州都允许某种形式的摄像机进入。而且这些试验在很大程度上进展顺利。摄像机在法庭中变得如此普遍，以至于到1991年，出现了一个专门为此设立的电视网，叫做庭审频道（Court TV）。加利福尼亚州诉伊丽莎白·安布鲁格案，女士们先生们，今天早上的业务议程，将从律师的开场陈述和开场陈述开始。
with broadcast coverage of judicial proceedings. By the 1990s, most states allowed some sort of camera access. And the experiments, for the most part, went well. Cameras became so common in the courtrooms that by 1991, there was a whole television network dedicated to it, called court TV. The matter of the people of state of California versus Elizabeth Ambrugger, order of business this morning, ladies and gentlemen, will start with the opening statements by the lawyers and opening statement.
简·柯特利说，很快，甚至自20世纪40年代以来对摄像机实行更严格禁令的联邦法院，也开始试水并转播他们的审判。据所有人估计，联邦试验进展得非常顺利。我曾有一年在美国律师协会年会的小组讨论会上谈论过这件事，联邦法官提出的唯一抱怨是媒体不够频繁地来记录审判。为什么他们不来报道我们那些迷人的版权案件之类的事情呢？但没有人对它有任何抱怨。像门内兹兄弟和杰弗里·达莫这样巨大的备受瞩目的案件
Jane Curley says that soon even federal courts, which had a much more stringent ban on cameras since the 1940s, also began testing the waters and televising their trials. Federal experiment was going very well by everybody's estimation. I was on a panel at the American Bar Association annual meeting one year and we were talking about it and only complaint that was coming from the federal judges were that the media weren't coming off and enough to record the trials. Why aren't they coming to our fascinating copyright cases and things like that? But nobody had any complaints about it. Huge high-profile cases like the Menendez brothers
都在电视上进行了从头到尾的转播。随着20世纪90年代摄像机越来越成为常态，一些法庭艺术家担心他们的工作面临危险。当审判的每一个时刻都在电视上实时即时记录时，电视网雇佣插画师还有什么意义？我想所有的法庭艺术家都以为那是法庭艺术的终点。法庭艺术家莫娜·谢弗·爱德华兹再次说道。她当时实际上开始为自己的职业生涯做备用计划。
and Jeffrey Dahmer were all aired gavill to gavill on television. With video cameras becoming more and more the norm in the 1990s, some court-martis were worried that their jobs were in danger. What was the point of a network hiring an illustrator when every single trial moment was instantaneously documented live on television? I think all of the court-room artists thought that was going to be the end of court-room art. Court-room artist Mona Schaefer Edwards again. She actually started making backup plans for her career around this time.
这非常有趣，因为我想，好吧，我还是回去做时尚吧，因为我依然喜欢它。而且我很擅长它。我想，好吧，这是一次美好的经历。然后辛普森案发生了。如果你在过去几个小时里一直在看电视，你一定在看搜寻O·J·辛普森的行动。那场搜寻今晚在……的目光下结束了。
It was very funny because I thought, okay, I'll go back to fashion because I still like it. And I'm good at it. And I thought, okay, well, this was a nice run. And then the OJ Simpson case happened. If you've been watching television over the past couple of hours, you've been watching the search for OJ Simpson. And that search ended tonight under the eye. Beginning in 1995 the city of Los Angeles began the ruling eight and a half month criminal
从1995年开始，洛杉矶市开始了对O·J·辛普森长达八个半月的刑事审判。如果你在1995年活着，你对这场审判的持久记忆可能就是它变成了一个彻头彻尾的笑话。他们从全球各地赶来，带来了他们的卫星转播车，拉了数英里的电缆。我找到了49名摄像师，25名主播，20名制作人，我能看到，但他们当中很多人并不在卡车里。主审法官兰斯·伊藤法官似乎绝对没有能力管理法庭上的戏剧性事件。记住这些话。
trial of OJ Simpson. If you were alive in 1995 your lasting memory of this trial was probably that it devolved into a total joke. They have come from across the globe bringing their satellite trucks pulling miles of cable? I found 49 camera men, 25 anchors, 20 producers I could see but a lot of them weren't that truck. The presiding judge, Judge Lance Edo, seemed absolutely incapable of managing court romantics. Remember these words.
如果它不合身，你必须宣告无罪。大多数观察家将其归咎于臃肿的媒体存在。这完全是一场马戏团，一场彻底的马戏团。尽管摄像机因这场审判而破例被允许进入法庭，但莫娜·谢弗·爱德华兹也被雇佣，与其他媒体一起绘制了初步听证会和刑事审判的速写。她说，那种滑稽剧般的氛围是显而易见的。
If it doesn't fit, you must acquit. And most observers blame the bloated media presence. It was totally a circus, a complete circus. Although cameras were famously allowed inside the courtroom for this trial, Mona Schaefer Edwards was also hired to sketch both the preliminary hearing and the criminal trial alongside other media. She says that the clonery was palpable.
在初审中，他们确实有一些证人，有趣的是，到了刑事审判时，他们进行了彻底的改头换面。我确实记得约翰尼·科克伦，他是一个可爱的人。他每天都来到法庭，他会把讲台调整到正对着摄像机角度的地方。然后那些证人，他们盛装打扮，做好了头发。让摄像机对着证人，绝对会给证人的证词涂上主观色彩。
In the preliminary trial, they did have some witnesses who, funnily enough, by the time it was the criminal trial, had total makeovers. And I do remember Johnny Cochran, who was a lovely man. He came into court every day, and he would adjust the lectern right where the camera angle. And then the witnesses, they were dressed up, they had a hair done. It absolutely colors a witness's testimony to have a camera on them.
对于那些几十年来一直辩称摄像机技术不会造成干扰、证人不会被镜头吓倒、律师不会哗众取宠、司法系统的诚信不会受到损害的媒体透明度倡导者来说，辛普森案似乎证明了完全相反的结果。喜剧演员连续八个月拿这场双重谋杀案开玩笑。杰·雷诺甚至每晚都让一排扮演伊藤法官的合唱团员表演编排好的爵士舞。全国各地的州和联邦法官在电视上直播了这一切的展开，
For media transparency advocates who had argued for decades that camera technology wasn't disruptive, that witnesses wouldn't be intimidated by the camera lens. That lawyers weren't going to put on a dog and pony show, that the integrity of the justice system wouldn't be compromised. The OJ Simpson trial seemed to prove the exact opposite. Comedians made a mockery out of this double murder trial for eight straight months. J. Leno even featured a chorus line of judge Edo impersonators performing choreographed jazz numbers every night. State and federal judges all over the country saw this unfurling live on television and
并将其视为如果将摄像机带入他们的法庭可能会发生在他们身上的一个例子。我所了解、尊敬和喜爱的那些联邦法官，他们原本完全支持摄像机，突然说我们不能让这种事情发生。这是一场正在酝酿的灾难。因此，蛇再次咬住了自己的尾巴，全国各地的法官毫不客气地将录音技术驱逐出他们的法庭。
took it as an example of what could happen to them if they brought cameras into their courtrooms. And judges, federal judges who I know respect and like, who had been all on board for cameras suddenly said we can't have this. This is a disaster in the making. So once again, the snake rounded back on its own tail as judges across the nation unceremoniously banished recording technology from their courtrooms. And cameras are still prohibited at the federal district court level except for ceremonial
在联邦地区法院层面，摄像机仍然被禁止，除了诸如宣誓加入公民籍等礼仪性程序之外。你可以从邻近的辛普森案到该政策画一条直线。因此，这种循环性为速写艺术家争取到了一次暂缓执行。当然，你知道犯罪永远不会停止，对吧？我们开始有这些惊人的、真正可怕的犯罪。法庭艺术家帕特·洛佩斯再次说道。她说，后辛普森时代对她这样的法庭艺术家来说实际上是一个淘金热时代。
proceedings like swearing in for a citizenship, that sort of thing. And you can draw a straight line from the adjacent Simpson trial to that policy. Accordingly this circularity granted a state of execution for sketch artists. Of course, you know crime never stops, right? And we started having these amazing, just really horrific crimes. Courtroom artist Pat Lopez again. She says that the post-OJ years were actually a gold rush era for Courtroom artists like her.
事实上，我曾有一天要画三场审判。我从达拉斯开始，他们用飞机把我送到休斯敦报道赛琳娜案。那里有一场听证会，然后我一天之内又回到了韦科。我忙得不可开交。因为那个原因，从1994年到1999年左右，我有做不完的工作。1999年左右，也是因为那个。尽管经历了多年的拉锯战，摄像机仍然被置于一个法律的灰色地带。
In fact, I had three trials going in one day. I started out in Dallas, and they flew me to Houston for Selina. There was a hearing there, and then I went back to Waco in one day. I could not turn around. I had so much work from 1994 until 1999, probably, because of that. 1999 probably because of that. Despite years of push and pull and push, cameras are still kept in a legal gray area.
它们在所有联邦法院以及大多数州和刑事法院仍然被禁止，具体因案件而异。尽管今天我们已经开发出了记录审判的更离散的方式，比如音频和视频流媒体，但许多法官仍然对将任何形式的录音技术引入法庭感到犹豫不决。说实话，我最初对法庭里的摄像机抱有轻微的怀疑态度。作为一个以对着麦克风说话为生的人，我敏锐地意识到，如果有人
They're still banned in all federal courts and in most state and criminal courts, it varies from case to case. And although today we've developed much more discrete ways to record a trial like audio and video streaming, many judges are still hesitant to bring any sort of recording technology into the courtroom. To be honest, I came into the story slightly skeptical of cameras in courtrooms. As a person who literally talks into a microphone for a living, I am acutely aware that if someone
知道自己正在被录音，这至少会微妙地改变他们的行为。比如，你觉得我的声音在现实生活中真的是这样的吗？不是的。真人薇薇安听起来更像詹妮弗·库利奇。因此，当司法系统本身已经让人感觉如此脆弱，当被告和案件受害者的利害关系如此重大，当某人的生命可能处于危险之中时，我禁不住想，为什么要冒险引入任何哪怕再小的、可能对法庭上发生的事情产生负面影响的因素呢？
knows they are being recorded, it can at least subtly change their behavior. Like, do you think my voice actually sounds like this in real life? No. In-person Vivian sounds more like Jennifer Coolidge. So when the Justice system already feels so fragile, when there's so much on the line for the defendant and the victims of the case, when someone's life could be on the line, I wondered why risk introducing any element,
直到遇到这样一个案件。我收集节目为您带来必将成为我们时代最受关注且最具潜在影响力的审判之一的现场报道——德里克·肖万的谋杀案审判。2021年3月，谋杀乔治·弗洛伊德的警察德里克·肖万的审判在明尼苏达州明尼阿波利斯开始。在审判期间，明尼苏达州实际上对刑事法庭中的电子媒体有着非常严格的规则。
no matter how small, that can negatively impact what happens in a court of law. That is until one case. I gather programming to bring you live coverage of what is certain to be one of the most closely watched and potentially consequential trials of our time, the murder trial of Derek Chauvin. In March of 2021, the trial of Derek Chauvin, the police officer who murdered George Floyd, began in Minneapolis, Minnesota. At the time of the trial, Minnesota actually had very stringent rules regarding electronic
柯特利说，该州此前一直极其不愿意允许摄像机进入。基本上，从被告到控方的每个参与者都必须允许在审判过程中进行录音。如果有任何人反对，那就没戏了。实际上，这意味着审判中从来没有摄像机。本案的检察官确实反对电视转播审判，但由于疫情封锁极大地限制了法庭内的记者人数，而且由于该案具有极高的公众利益，
media in criminal courtrooms. Curly says that the state had already been incredibly reluctant to allow cameras at all. Essentially, everyone involved from the defendants to the prosecution had to give permission to allow recording during the trial process. If anyone objected, that was the end of it. And practically that meant that there were never cameras in trial. The prosecutor in the case did oppose televising the trial, but because the COVID lockdown drastically limited the number of press in the courtroom and because the case was of such a high public interest,
主审法官彼得·卡希尔顶住了反对意见，开创了先例。卡希尔法官决定，整个审判过程需要向全球进行现场直播。如果在肖万审判时没有那些实行的疫情限制措施，我认为卡希尔法官不太可能（尽管并非不可能）同意在法庭内放置摄像机。卡希尔法官为广播制定了许多基本规则，以便在问题发生之前将其缓解。陪审团成员不得被录音。
the presiding judge Peter Kale went against him in the soda precedent. Judge Kale decided that the entirety of the trial needed to stream live for the world to see. Had we not had the pandemic restrictions that were in place at this time of the show of entrial, I think it is unlikely, although not impossible, that Judge K. Hill would have consented to having cameras in the courtroom. Judge K. Hill set a lot of ground rules for the broadcasts in order to mitigate problems before they happened. Jurors were not allowed to be recorded.
对哪些证人可以被拍摄有限制，摄像机的移动也受到了限制。但是，打破历史的是，审判的广播几乎顺利完成。没有任何滑稽动作，没有人报告说感到受到威胁，在这段经历之后，原本反对广播的主检察官完全改变了看法，现在成为了法庭摄像机的支持者。我认为这次转播的情况和在这种情况下可能达到的最好结果一样好，甚至更好。
There were restrictions on which witnesses could be filmed, and the movement of the cameras was limited. But, in a break with history, the broadcast of the trial went off nearly hitch-free. There were no antics, no one reported being intimidated, and after this experience, the lead prosecutor, who had originally opposed the broadcast, changed his view entirely, and is now a supporter of cameras in the court. I think this went as well or better as could ever have been expected under the circumstances.
2023年3月，在肖万案的深刻影响下，明尼苏达州最高法院裁决扩大州刑事审判中的摄像机权限。从2024年开始，转播法庭诉讼程序将不再需要辩方和控方的双重许可。今年早些时候，参议员格拉斯利和德宾提出了一项两党法案，旨在首次将摄像机引入最高法院。最高法院历来不以对变革、技术或透明度采取非常放松的态度而闻名，前大法官苏特曾有一句名言：
In March of 2023, largely influenced by the Chauvin trial, the Minnesota Supreme Court ruled to expand camera access in state criminal trials. Starting in 2024, permission from both the defense and the prosecution will no longer be required to broadcast courtroom proceedings. And earlier this year, Senators Grassley and Durban introduced a bipartisan bill that would bring cameras into the Supreme Court for the first time. The court has never really been known for being super chill about things like change or technology or transparency and former Justice Souter once famously said,
“引述一下，你们看到摄像机进入我们法庭的那一天，将是从我的尸体上碾过去。”因此，该法案是否能真正通过很难说。至少目前，法庭艺术家还是安全的。20年前我也没有看到它的未来。我一直以为这是最后一年，这是最后一年，这是最后一年，但它一直在发生。法庭艺术家莫娜·谢弗·爱德华兹再次说道。我不知道未来会怎样，
quote, the day you see a camera come into our courtroom, it's going to roll over my dead body end quote. So whether that bill would ever actually pass is hard to say. At least for now, courtroom artists are still safe. I didn't see a future in 20 years ago either. I kept thinking this is the last year, this is the last year, this is the last year, but it keeps happening. Courtroom artist Mona Schaefer Edwards again. I don't know how it's going to go,
但这段经历很棒，我很喜欢它，只要我能做到，我就想一直画下去。有些审判，人们普遍认为法庭艺术家比摄像机更合适，比如涉及家庭暴力、性侵犯或包含未成年人的敏感案件。而且无法保证其他电视转播的高调案件能像明尼苏达州的那个案件那样顺利进行。
but it's been great, and I love it, and as long as I can do it, then I would like to just keep on doing it. There are some trials that people generally agree are better served by courtroom artists than by cameras, sensitive cases that involve domestic abuse, sexual assault, or that include minors. And there's no guarantee other televised high profile cases would go as smoothly as the one in Minnesota.
简·柯特利承认，肖万案直播之所以广受欢迎，部分原因在于它以定罪告终。如果结果相反，谁知道公众会作何反应。但摄像机倡导者认为，如果亲眼看到我们的司法系统运作让你感到愤怒，也许那是因为你本就该感到愤怒。如果你看不到一个系统是坏的，你就无法修复它。接下来，薇薇安将帮我解开一个最高法院的谜团。广告之后见。我们和制作人薇薇安·莱回来了。薇薇安，你现在可以向法庭陈述了。
Jane Curately acknowledges that part of the reason why the livestream of the show in trial was so well received was because it ended with a conviction. Had it gone the other way, who knows what the public response would have been. But camera advocates think that if actually seeing our justice system in action makes you angry, maybe it's because you should be angry. You can't fix a system if you can't see it's broken. Coming up, Vivian helps me get to the bottom of a Supreme Court mystery. After this. We are back with producer Vivian Le. Vivian, you may now address the court.
谢谢。谢谢，法官大人。请坐。你给我们带来了什么？是的，所以我想和你多聊聊最高法院及其与电视报道的关系，特别是电视报道已经被禁止了几十年了。是的，我们在主线故事中稍微触及了这一点。是的，是的。所以最高法院实际上会记录辩论本身的音频，如果人们不知道的话，它已经公开很长时间了，你们应该去听听。太酷了。
Thank you. Thank you, your honor. Please be here. What do you have for us? Yes, so I wanted to talk a little bit more with you about the Supreme Court and its relationship to television coverage in particular, which has been banned for decades. Yeah, we touched a little bit on this in the main story. Yes, yeah. So the Supreme Court actually, it does record audio of the arguments themselves, which has been publicly accessible for a while if people don't know, you should check it out. So cool.
是的，但法院一直对现场报道或特别是电视报道非常谨慎。是的，我的意思是，几十年来人们一直在推动为最高法院设立一个类似于C-SPAN的节目，因为实时体验这些辩论与几天后通过录音收听是如此不同。这太不同了。
Yeah, but the court has always been like, really skittish about live coverage or television coverage in particular. Yeah, I mean, people have been pushing for decades to have a version of C-SPAN for the Supreme Court because it's just so different to experience these arguments in real time versus days later in an audio recording. It's just so different.
没错，所以在几年前，最高法院确实破例首次允许对口头辩论进行现场音频流媒体播放。这纯粹是因为（你知道的）我们目前正在不同城市的独立房间里录制这个尾声的完全相同的原因，那就是新冠疫情。是的，因为新冠疫情，大法官们无法亲自会面。因此他们开始允许公众访问实时进行的这些电话会议，这把我带到了我把你带到这里的真正原因。我知道这要走向何方。我知道这要走向何方。好吧。但对于还没反应过来的人来说，在2020年5月6日星期三，发生了一件事，它是历史性的，而且我将
Right, so a few years ago, the Supreme Court did allow for the first time live audio streaming of oral arguments. And it was for, you know, exactly the same reason why we are currently recording this Coda in separate rooms in different cities, which is COVID. Yes, because of COVID, the justices could not meet in person. So they began allowing public access to these teleconference calls that were happening in real time, which leads me to the actual reason why I brought here. I know where this is going. I know where this is going. Okay. But for people who haven't caught on yet on Wednesday, May 6, 2020, something happened and it was historic and I'm going
没错，所以在几年前，最高法院首次允许对口头辩论进行现场音频直播。原因嘛，正如我们目前正在不同城市的独立房间里录制这期 Coda 播客的原因完全一样，那就是疫情。是的，因为疫情，大法官们无法当面开会。因此，他们开始允许公众实时收听这些电话会议，这就引出了我把你请到这里的真正原因。我知道这要聊到哪里去了。我知道这要聊到哪里去了。好的。但是对于还没反应过来的听众，在2020年5月6日星期三，发生了一件具有历史意义的事，而我打算...
to play the clip right now. FCC has said is that when the subject matter of the call ranges to suspects, then the call is transformed and it's a call that was been allowed. Yes, the Supreme Court toilet flush. That's toilet flush. So for listeners who have been living under a rock, smack dab in the middle of oral arguments, someone on the Supreme Court, maybe not on the Supreme Court, but on the Supreme Court phone call, forgot to hit mute, and a very audible toilet flush
现在播放这段录音。联邦通信委员会（FCC）表示，当通话的主题涉及嫌疑人时，该通话就会发生转变，变成一个被允许的通话。是的，最高法院的冲水声。那是冲水声。所以对于那些消息闭塞的听众来说，就在口头辩论进行得正激烈时，最高法院里的某个人——也许不在最高法院里，但就在最高法院的电话会议上——忘记按静音了，一个非常清晰的冲水声
rang out for the entire world to hear. This is like my worst nightmare. It is a complete nightmare. And a nightmare for the Supreme Court justices on the call, because of course, the next logical question after like, was that a toilet flush? Is who flushed the toilet? Yeah.
在全世界听众面前响起。这就像是我的噩梦。这简直是个彻底的噩梦。对于参加电话会议的最高法院大法官们来说也是个噩梦，因为当然了，在诸如“刚才那是冲水声吗？”之后，下一个合乎逻辑的问题就是：是谁冲的马桶？是的。
So I never actually found out who that was. Did anyone ever find out who the Phantom toilet flusher was? OK, so there is an incredible slate article by Ashley Feinberg, who is the best detective in the world. She's the one who found out that Mitt Romney was tweeting under the pseudonym Pierre de Lecto. She's very skilled. She did probably the most in-depth investigative reporting on the subject, and I really, really wanted to
所以我其实一直没查出来那个人是谁。有人查出那个“幽灵冲水客”到底是谁吗？好吧，Slate网站上有一篇不可思议的文章，作者是阿什利·范伯格（Ashley Feinberg），她是全世界最厉害的侦探。她就是那个发现米特·罗姆尼（Mitt Romney）曾用皮埃尔·德莱克托（Pierre de Lecto）这个化名发推特的人。她非常厉害。她对这个话题进行了可以说是最深入的调查报道，我真的、真的很想
share some of her findings. Okay, well, I'm a little nervous to where this is going to go, but let's go for it. Okay, so although it is not impossible, it is very unlikely that it was either Roman Martinez, who was the lawyer who you hear actively speaking on Mike at the time. And it was probably not just this Kagan because this was during her round of questioning. So she was also just on Mike. Okay. Okay. That'd be a huge power move if she was doing it.
分享她的一些发现。好吧，对于这件事会走向何方我有点紧张，但我们开始吧。好的，虽然这并非不可能，但基本上可以排除罗曼·马丁内斯（Roman Martinez），他就是你在麦克风里听到正在积极发言的律师。而且大概也不是卡根大法官，因为当时正轮到她提问。所以她当时也刚好在用麦克风。好吧。好吧。如果真的是她干的，那可真是一次极权力的宣示。
Totally. Yeah. From the toilet. Yeah. And so it also probably wasn't Ruth Bader Ginsburg because Ginsburg at the time was actually in the hospital, she took this call from the hospital and every time it was her turn to speak, you could kind of hear like this background noise and that wasn't present during the time of the flush. But the main person of interest is Justice Breyer. Okay. So why Justice Breyer? It is important to note that Justice Breyer did not confess to being the toilet flusher nor do we have definitive proof that it was him. Okay.
完全赞同。是的。从马桶上。是的。所以大概也不是鲁思·巴德·金斯伯格（Ruth Bader Ginsburg），因为金斯伯格当时其实在医院里，她是是从医院接入这个电话的，而且每次轮到她发言时，你都能听到类似这样的背景噪音，而冲水声出现的时候并没有这种噪音。但主要的嫌疑人是布雷耶大法官（Justice Breyer）。好吧。那么为什么是布雷耶大法官呢？需要指出的是，布雷耶大法官并没有承认自己是冲水的那个人，我们也没有确凿的证据证明就是他。好吧。
Notice. But Feinberg sites a number of things here. For one, Breyer had a number of technical difficulties during the call. Like, you could hear audible clinking in the background during some of the moments that he was on mic. So it kind of indicated that, you know, he wasn't too worried about multitasking during oral arguments. Yeah, yeah. Or wasn't familiar with the muting and unmuting that we've gotten so adept at in our years of Zoom.
注意。但范伯格在这里列举了许多事情。首先，布雷耶在通话期间遇到了许多技术困难。比如，在他使用麦克风的某些时刻，你能听到背景中有明显的叮当声。这在某种程度上表明，你知道的，他在口头辩论期间对于一心多用并不是太担心。是的，是的。或者说不太熟悉我们在Zoom时代已经变得如此熟练的静音和取消静音的操作。
Yes, exactly. And that brings me to the most damning piece of evidence that comes out of this investigation, which is the way in which some of the justices signed off at the ends of their rounds of questioning. What do you mean by that? When some of the justices were finished talking, there was a very subtle, audible dropout where you could tell that they had hit mute. So I'm going to play for you a clip from Clarence Thomas as he's finishing his questioning. And you're going to have to listen super closely
是的，没毛病。这就把我带到了这次调查中最确凿的证据，那就是某些大法官在结束他们的提问环节时挂断电话的方式。你这是什么意思？当一些大法官说完话时，会有一个非常微妙、清晰的音频中断，你能听出他们按下了静音。所以我要给大家播放一段克拉伦斯·托马斯（Clarence Thomas）在结束提问时的录音。你们必须要极其仔细地聆听
to the ambient noise in between Thomas's voice and the voice that comes after it. And even someone knocking on their front door. Well, I think... So you can hear a little bit of a drop out there and then I'm also gonna play Sotomayor too so you can get a sense of what Sotomayor did too. The remedy shouldn't we let the circuit below decide that question.
托马斯的声音与紧随其后的声音之间的环境噪音。甚至还有人敲击他们前门的声音。嗯，我想……所以你可以在那里听到一点音频中断，然后我还要播放索托马约尔（Sotomayor）的录音，这样你们也能感受到索托马约尔是怎么做的。补救措施难道我们不应该让下级巡回法院来决定那个问题吗？
But you're on it to two points on that. So right there, you hear that right there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And it's hard to tell an audio, but fineberg actually analyzed a visual waveform of these three. These three just back to back, which is right there in the, I just zoomed you picture a room and if you tell me what you see. Yeah, so it has the Thomas wave form, which has normal audio waves that you see.
但是你正说到这两点上。所以就在这里，你听到那个声音了吗？是的，是的，是的。而且仅凭音频很难分辨，但范伯格实际上分析了这三个人的视觉波形。这三个人是一个接一个的，就在那个，我刚刚放大让你想象一个房间，如果你告诉我你看到了什么。是的，所以它有托马斯的波形，显示出你所能看到的正常的音频波。尔后当静音时，当他们说完话时，就变成了空白。就像没有声音一样。然后索托马约尔也是一样的。她说完话，她挂断，变成静音。但是布雷耶有那种类似说话的小峰值。然后当他说完话时，你仍然能听到那些微弱的环境噪音，就好像他不知道，或者在这个例子中，他没有按静音。是的，没毛病。所以他是头号嫌疑人。再次声明，没有确凿的证据，但我认为这是我们目前能找到的最接近答案的线索了，除非他在临终前坦白。但是你知道的，
And then when it goes to mute, when they're done talking, it goes to nothing. Like there's no sound. And then sort of my or is the same thing. She talks, she signs off, it goes to mute. But Breyer has like the little peaks of talking. And then when he's done talking, you still have those little ambient, like little peaks though low, as if he didn't know or in this case, he did not mute. Yes, exactly. So he is the lead suspect. Again, no definitive proof, but I think that's the closest that we could get to an answer for now, and so he confesses on his deathbed. But you know,
这个冲水事件太搞笑了，因为最高法院不遗余力地想要展现这种宏大和尊严的氛围。比如他们穿着黑色的长袍，坐在桃花心木的高台阶上。你知道的，那个人走下来，然后他，他念着开庭的赞词。在他们旁边还有这些小小的、可爱的鹅毛笔。对的，对的。但当你，你知道的，听他们的辩论甚至是书面辩论时，他们其实也就是普通人，他们有时也会提出非常糟糕的论点并做出愚蠢的决定。
this toilet thing is so funny because there's a pream court goes to such great lengths to like project this air of grandeur and dignity. Like they wear these black robes and they sit on this elevated bench of mahogany. You know, the guy comes down and he goes, he does the OEA chant thing. And they have these little, these cute little quill pens next to them. Right, right. But when you like, you know, listen to their arguments and even written arguments, they're just human beings and they sometimes make really bad arguments and make dumb decisions.
他们也会上厕所，而且他们也会遇到Zoom的技术问题。是的。有很多充分的理由去质疑最高法院的尊严，但人有三急。好吧，我很高兴你能把这个重要问题带给我们听众。所以，罗曼，为了你的面子，我省去了阿什利·范伯格的冲水调查中许多搞笑的细节。所以如果听众想亲自去了解，我们会在我们的网站上提供一个链接。这太棒了。好吧，非常感谢。
And they also use toilets and they have IT Zoom issues. Yes. There's a lot of good reasons to question the dignity of the Supreme Court, but everybody poops. Well, I'm so glad you could bring this important issue to our audience. So, Roman, for your sake, I left out a lot of hilarious details from Ashley Feinberg's Toilet Flush investigation. So, listeners want to check that out for themselves. We'll have a link to that on our website. This is great. Well, thank you so much.
我很感激。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由薇薇安·莱（Vivian Lay）制作，凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）剪辑。原创音乐由斯旺·里豪（Swan Rihau）创作。声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）完成。杜兰·耶豪（Tulane Yehaw）是我们的资深编辑，库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Colestet）是我们的数字总监。制作团队包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉什·马登（Lash Maddon）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。
I appreciate it. Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by By Vivian Lay And Edited By Kelly Prime Original Music By Swan Rihau Sound Mixed By Martin Gonzalez Tulane Yehaw is our Senior Editor, Kurt Colestet is our Digital Director. Throws a Team Includes Chris Baroube, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lash Maddon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
本周要特别感谢海丁·尼舍里（Heading Nisheri），他的书《法院电视时代的犯罪与司法》对这个故事非常有帮助，还要感谢瑞秋·沃德（Rachel Ward）提供的额外编辑支持。还要感谢贾里德·埃尔南德斯（Jared Hernandez），他为本集创作了两幅精彩的原创法庭素描，尽管我对他是如何描绘我的鼻子有些异议。
Special thanks this week to Heading Nisheri, whose book Crime and Justice in the Age of Court TV was really helpful to this story and to Rachel Ward for additional editorial support. Also thanks to Jared Hernandez, who created two amazing original courtroom sketches for this episode, although I have some objection to how he depicted my nose.
它可能确实有那么大，但没有那么圆。不过不管怎样，谢谢你，贾里德。我想是的。你可以在我们的网站上查看这些素描。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在前往我们在潘多拉大厦以北6个街区的总部。坐落于美丽的。上城。
It is maybe that big, but it is not that round. But anyway, thank you, Jared. I guess. You can check those out at our website. We are a part of this Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now head to our 6 blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在Facebook上找到本节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我，账号是Roman Mars，也可以@本节目，账号是99PI org。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI过去的每一集节目。中正 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. 中正 There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
中正 本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。